craig clev it has a problem a big
problem he's just 30 years old and
already deep in debt he's brought a
cardboard box out of the basement full
of unpaid bills and demands for payment
for amounts he can't raise every day
collection agencies phone him and
pressing for payment Craig is more than
200,000 US dollars in debt because he
studied at one of the art institutes a
system of for-profit art colleges that
earn money on students basically they
said yeah it's a it costs a lot but
it'll be worth it because you'll be able
to pay it right out of the gate and
you'll be making more than everyone else
when you're you know in the workforce
Craig believed the art institutes
promises the AI offers courses in design
art and fashion and students paid big
bucks for them very big bucks to finance
them AI offers loans guaranteed publicly
by the federal government and privately
by banks which makes drawings appear
three-dimensional when Craig signed them
he thought he was doing just the right
thing it might just change your
perspective they definitely sugar-coated
it why not they were telling me about it
and how much how much it would you know
accrue interest over time and how much I
would make to be able to pay it was
Craig just stupid was it his own fault
or is their method in this madness for
you guys to say when you want we're at a
legal service center in Boston
Massachusetts lawyer Toby Merrill works
here someone she knows many cases of
students who feel they've been bled dry
and suspect the private commercial
colleges target them specifically so the
business scheme is to target people who
won't be able to tell at least it not at
first that they are getting ripped off
so that includes low income people
people who are desperate to change their
situations there is an Art Institute
school
just around the corner from us here in
Massachusetts and so I've seen a number
of people who have borrowed just really
incredible sums of money and a lot of
them have had truly terrible experiences
the art institutes are run by a private
company education management corporation
EDMC for short the investment bank
Goldman Sachs owns forty-three percent
of its shares with more than 100
locations and more than 100,000 students
EDMC is the second largest provider of
for-profit colleges in the US it
receives billions and state subsidies
after getting his bachelor's degree in
media and design Craig withdrew to the
small town of torrington connecticut not
far from New York City and moved back in
with his mother he hasn't found the good
job the Institute promised in fact he's
working two jobs one in a bar and the
other at a filling station Craig has to
raise twelve hundred dollars a month to
make the payments and interest on his
private loans Craig works hard US law
decrees that even if he does file for
bankruptcy he still has to repay his
student loan we show Craig's case to
someone who knows ed mc's business
practices from her own experience
Kathleen Biddle used to work for the
company she recruited students got them
to sign loans and advised them they
definitely sugar-coated it when they
were telling me about it and how much it
would you know accrue interest over time
and she regrets it to this day so
hundreds against like him
it breaks my heart
what they do is just wrong on so many
levels everything he said was absolutely
true I saw it happen hundreds and
hundreds of times they're stealing
futures they're stealing futures they
promise them the world and they give
them nothing for it but debt our ed MCS
Art Institutes defrauding students ai's
parent company wrote us that the
accusations refer to the past in the
situation is different now on their
website the CEO makes assurances it is
in the very fabric of who we are as
chief executive officer I believe in a
culture that promotes compliance with
federal and state laws agency rules and
regulation Kathleen bill doesn't believe
him she says the company falsified
statistics to get public funding and
federal student loan money and that
still infuriates her being forced to
cook the books for the for the jobs it
was all about money it wasn't about
education in any way shape or form it
was all about money serious accusations
from a chief witness whose testimony is
now being dealt with by the legal
authorities state prosecutors like Glenn
Kaplan are demanding edmc return
government subsidies 11 billion dollars
in student loans are at stake the
company says the charges are unfounded
we have an investigation that is active
into them we are looking at them we are
reviewing allegations and complaints
that have been made about them loans
like the ones Craig signed in Boston
have long been passed on by the lenders
together with many others they're
packaged together and sold on as asset
backed securities to holding companies
like hypo real estate in Germany
is money in two places one because the
school's themselves charge so much more
than a non-profit or a public school
would and you you get all that money
coming in and then to to the extent that
private loans are made there's money to
be made when those loans are securitized
a nearly perfect system to get as much
money as possible from students like
Craig claw vet will be responsible for
those loans all his life I am on
antidepressants right now I am
completely stuck yeah
you